[Music]
question
where do you think your uh math
and science skills are at in terms of
grade level
[ __ ] kindergarten kindergarten no
doctor level doctor look okay oh that's
impressive uh
grade six high school depending on how
smart the high school student is high
school
i did better in geometry so i'll stop
there wherever that happens
science wise i always had a b
math wise always had an f how does that
work out you square that up how does
that work out because science needs math
no bro no okay never mind what do i know
all right so
in a poll uh the average
knows nothing no it's nothing exactly
accurate and that they
think their science and math level taps
out at
sixth grade yes yeah you know what i
came up with that
how america reads at a sixth grade
reading level because all of the
new york times bestsellers and the best
books of all are you smarter
grade reading level are you smarter than
that's why some politicians only speak
at a sixth grade reading level by the
way
that's why trump goes wrong wrong wrong
wrong wrong time completely
wrong i agree with that yeah isaac's now
in seventh grade
and he's a great smarter than you he is
now a great smarter than me
he could read no i mean this year
because he's doing distance learning
he's doing schooling at home
so then we are like a little bit more
involved with the schooling because
compared to last year and the years
before that he was going to an
after-school program where they tutored
him and they would help him with
homework
so now i actually get to see his
schoolwork and now i'm like oh [ __ ] i
really don't know [ __ ] didn't they do
like a new form of math
too like the system said they changed
common core and it's ridiculously
complicated so isaac and me uh we're
about
we play vidya games uh sea of thieves we
do play seafood also among us
we play pirate game we do not play that
game i don't know what that game is
oh but we played fortnight and we played
pirate game
okay that kid put a [ __ ] song on my
head
for days it's his [ __ ] stupid
dynamite
yes dynamite dynamite oh is it the bts
song cause he just got a new dance on
fortnite he attended the concert and he
got the dance
he would not stop singing it and then it
got in my head and then i told nikki i
was like
i was going to bed and i was like baby i
got the song stuck in my head i'm sorry
i have to tell you about it
and then she got stuck in her head she
hadn't even heard it from isaac
that kid is a virus they say to forget a
song that's stuck in your head you have
to
get to the end of the song so you know
how to close it
oh so yeah they say that we breaks the
curse we repeat certain parts because
that's all we know but if you list
if you can get it to think of how the
song ends the song is over
whether the song fades out and it's just
it's on loop at the end it just fades
down you're like
that was that that song so you're saying
it's like
you have to get to learn what the end of
the song is it's like the movie big
where i have to go
find the fortune teller thing and why
would you want it to end if it's so good
it's not crazy there are certain songs
where like there's no reason why you
live in my brain right now i
listen to a song non-stop since this
morning till i got here
what's the song one song i don't even
know the name there's a difference
between listening to a song on repeat
and a song being stuck it's called an
ear worm
it's been playing in my head because i
can't listen to it what's the song
there's no name do the lyric then
that's it wait that's it it's a romanian
kind of song
what the hell are you watching and
listening to you know what i'm listening
to
and it's hilarious yes yeah
but yes i find a lot of music
and it gets stuck right now the song is
stuck in my head i don't know the end of
dynamite
no if anybody sends you something that
you should just watch all the way
through it's this [ __ ] right
here i send gold he sends gold every
time
well it depends on your sons of humor
but yes
she's like if you like the romanian
music industry you'll find history
that was for nikki blades not for
old-ass married chicks okay
thank you oh well you and i know you're
jealous thank you
but yeah so back to sixth grade uh level
of we were just trying to ignore the
fact that we are not smarter than why
are you bringing us back to feeling dumb
we are dumb and that's exactly the
problem because now
it's the pandemics pose the new problem
is that
if they can't be if kids students cannot
be
uh in the classroom and getting help
one-on-one help from a teacher
that's more step sixth grader exactly
who steps in place
of that tutor that teacher google the
parents that are stuck at sixth grade
and if you're
if your child's in seventh grade or
onward then basically where we are now
yeah isaac's in seventh grade he's
completely [ __ ] if he
also the fact that the common core
[ __ ] luckily though
matt is isaac's strongest subject oh he
has an a
plus he actually has an a plus all
throughout all of his subjects right now
congratulations you're a [ __ ] gambler
you just rolled
a seven that's that's all you told me
has nothing to do with you uh no it
actually does because i raised him to be
a meth genius oh my bad
just kidding there are a lot of parents
struggling i heard
that one of the people that i know that
works at a school
has to show up because some of the
parents aren't even making their kids go
to their classes
like and they're at home so it's like if
you have your own issues
and then now you're forced to have to
like make sure you're i mean there is a
point in time that you can
send them out and go to school there are
a lot of parents that are realizing like
yo
i am not a [ __ ] teacher and joe is
three of those parents mm-hmm
all in one and that's why he has no
business
yet i feel like i would be one of those
parents that are like
ask the wife i do that a lot i
like defer to mom i don't know but then
also i'm like
daddy knows he's just confused in the
middle and then he's like listen neither
one of you [ __ ] know any just
parents are idiots i don't think i'd
emphasize school that hard like yeah
yeah i feel like now there's so many
ways to get information
and it's how a kid solves a problem and
maybe school be
important for structure discipline and
maybe listening
to a team and whatever but then ability
to like follow through
of your responsibilities because like
for him he has to make sure to check
in at a certain time for every period he
has to make sure to turn
in every single assignment that he has
he has to make sure to do the
assignments the correct way that the
teacher laid out for him to do
and it's a lot it's just mainly teaching
responsibility i think
and he's a really responsible kid nelson
would you feel personally responsible
for your kid
if they didn't know math uh
yeah why because you feel like it's your
duty to teach them
what do you mean by don't know math like
they don't know if they don't know
what's
and then go bite somebody's leg while
they're riding a bicycle or something
because
i think beyond like what tim was saying
beyond teaching them the actual math is
teaching them
the personal responsibility because i
feel like what a lot of parents are
experiencing right now
is what immigrant parents experience
when they move here because they can't
help their kids with like
english or whatever yeah right like
you're gonna ask your parents for help
when you're
when they can't even speak english like
you can't do that yeah that's true
i love i coach so i used to coach kids
and run like youth programs
and i see a lot of the parents that just
struggle with even basic nutrition that
most parents don't know there's so much
that
as adults they don't realize are
important to teach their children and a
lot of parents are just raising their
kids but not teaching their kids
so right now during all of it my brain
works different i would be very hands-on
i like doing those types of things i
turn everything into a lesson with my
nieces we do a lot of stuff that always
has things learning involved
that's just because what i like to do i
enjoy that type of stuff
but i know that my sister who enjoys the
same thing
has two babies one in kindergarten and
one in elementary
i mean one in first grade and she's like
no matter
how much i enjoy doing this and i love
being with my kids and she loves the
like
okay this is water this is h2o let's
talk about science to talk about this
thing she's like
it's a different [ __ ] ball game when
it comes to the lessons when it comes to
the attention
how do you get a kindergartener and a
first grader to sit in front of a
computer first off they have to learn
how to use a computer
then you have to do things like uh cyber
work
workouts it's not fun it's not fun and
then as a parent you guys have to learn
what the teachers are teaching because
we can decide
that's not what we want our kids to do
but if we want our kids to pass to
possibly go on and further their
education
guess what they have to conform in order
to pass so that they can eventually do
much work
yeah it's a lot of work but i think the
immigrant parent conversation
is spot on and if that doesn't give you
a little bit of empathy because i'd be
like
yo [ __ ] this let's go to the beach and
dig some [ __ ] holes
true and then me and my kids would just
try to dig the biggest hole
would you try and that's why when we
split custody that's why we
split custody with the children yeah um
in our duplex we're gonna have a big
enough house we're gonna be like
daddy's over here and the kids are like
your honor i i i i i love my parents i
only know how to dig holes
which one of them taught you that daddy
did
daddy taught me but mommy makes me
actually like count and do stuff like
mommy makes me ashamed of the holes i
dig
which parent would teach uh the formula
for calculating speed
my mom do we know that does anyone speed
the drug
the formula of calculating speed free
the drugs
yeah like miles per hour distance over
time distance
times something's not times uh
multiplier joe's like huff the nos
huff the knot don't this is what happens
don't do that phones everybody has
phones you can google it yeah distance
divided by time which is a typical sixth
grade science question kind of close
sort out because i said distance
something with time
i wasn't even close i was like pick up
your phone
true and if you didn't know it's okay
because according to the survey one in
five parents only know that so
one or five adults only wow i'm point
five you're 0.5
hey and you think puffy than us like is
pretty cool
and you should have blue hair too if you
have a job
is to love them make sure that they
don't go through all
life [ __ ] people over and then they
can learn
he's bringing the morals and i'm going
well since your father thinks that we
can just rest on our morals
snaps let me tell you about the real
world now this is tissue how much does
it cost to manufacture whatever
and this is wine and how much does it
cost you for your mommy to drink it
this is 13 alcohol remember we did math
now if mommy drinks this
and then finishes it off with bottle of
water how much alcohol is in her system
now if your mommy drinks this much wine
how much does it take her to forget
about daddy in percentages
well mommy did that two two and then
four water bottles and then dad took the
water bottle away and gave her another
wine bottle
so it's two wine bottles and so how long
has it been since mommy had sex with
daddy
from when you got born well daddy said
that your mom doesn't
like touch me anymore and i didn't know
what she meant because dad said remember
no touching nobody's
so i'm confused
[Music]
you